The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So I'm creating
a variable called pset_time
and I'm assigning it
to be the value 15.
I'm creating a variable
named sleep_time.
I'm assigning it
to be the value 8.
I'm going to print the value
of this expression here.
And the expression is a
conditional that says,
is sleep_time greater
than pset_time?
So in Python, you're just going
to replace these variables
with their values.
So is 8 greater than 15?
And that's false, so perfect.
And then one operation on
Booleans derive as true.
Drink is false.
I'm using the AND
operator to figure out
if I should drink
and derive, and I'm
going to print out false.
So, perfect, people
are getting it.
Great job, guys.